[Música]
bienvenidos a elecciones 2022 un tour
por francia en que analizamos los
principales temas de la campaña
electoral francesa tomamos dirección
hacia el aeropuerto porque nos vamos al
caribe
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la penúltima parada de nuestro autor por
francia es la isla de guadalupe en el
caribe a 7.000 km de parís una distancia
física que muchos aquí viven también
como política
[Música]
estoy enojada porque votamos por las
personas a las que no vemos nunca nunca
los escuchamos
el agua es vida si no tenemos agua no
podemos hacer nada
tenemos que ser capaces de salir de una
relación paternalista para entrar en una
relación de socios iguales
i
[Música]
la isla de guadalupe y su vecina
martinica vivieron en los últimos meses
semanas de protestas en contra de las
restricciones sanitarias impuestas por
parís el movimiento sirvió para abrir
las viejas heridas del pasado
los vestigios del imperio colonial
francés están repartidos en distintos
puntos del planeta en forma de
territorios administrados por francia
cinco de ellos han sido organizados en
forma de departamentos de ultramar o
departamentos franceses de ultramar
guadalupe y martinica en el caribe
cuyana francesa en américa del sur y
reunión y mayo está en el océano índico
según el último censo de 2017 28
millones de personas vivían en los
territorios de ultramar franceses
es decir un 4,1 por ciento de la
población total de francia al ser
ciudadanos franceses estas personas
votan en las elecciones nacionales
eligen 27 diputados para la asamblea
nacional y 21 senadores pero su
presentación en las instituciones de la
república no les garantiza igualdad de
oportunidades primero porque los
salarios en el extranjero son
significativamente más bajos que en
francia continental mientras que el
costo de los bienes esenciales como los
alimentos y el combustible suele ser
mucho más alto el 14 por ciento de los
ciudadanos franceses en francia
continental vive por debajo del umbral
de la pobreza esta tasa es más que el
doble en guadalupe donde llega un 34% y
se dispara hasta un 77 por ciento en
mayotté las cifras de mortalidad
infantil siguen el mismo parámetro en el
hexágono como se conoce a la francia
europea 33 de cada 1000 niños franceses
mueren antes de cumplir un año en
concordancia con la media de la unión
europea en martinica y la reunión los
decesos aumentan a 8 por cada 1000 niños
una tasa similar a la de kazajistán
legalmente hablando los territorios de
ultramar de francia son tan franceses
como cualquier otro lugar pero las
estadísticas en torno al bienestar y
nivel de vida demuestran con demasiada
frecuencia otra realidad durante las
últimas elecciones presidenciales
1 de cada 2 guadalupeños no votó
preguntamos a los isleños el porqué de
esta ruptura con el sistema democrático
es una población en plena efervescencia
que se cuestiona sobre su lugar en la
nación en la francia global y cuando
hablamos con los más jóvenes a menudo
tiene la impresión de que no forman
realmente parte de francia
estoy enojada porque votamos por
personas que no hemos nunca no los
escuchamos tampoco sólo se limitan a
pasar y decir esto haremos por los
jóvenes por los adultos mayores pero no
hacen nada pese a que todos somos
franceses al menos hasta ahora
hace 10 años que vivimos que ellos
escuchan sobre problemas de agua que han
existido hasta siempre que sepan que no
tenemos hospital lo saben pero no lo
entienden no toman medidas para que
nuestro sufrimiento se detenga
una de las frustraciones más importantes
en guadalupe tiene que ver con un vital
elemento si bien la isla cuenta con
numerosas fuentes de agua dulce el
sistema sanitario sufre hace años de
desorganización y falta de mantenimiento
la historia de karina ya borja
en este barrio de google
hago esto todas las mañanas cuando ya no
sale el agua del grifo tengo que venir
aquí a buscarla esto representa una gran
dificultad para libia rosinei obligada a
ser muy ingenioso
con su hija autista va regularmente a la
casa de sus suegros ellos tienen agua
pero no mucho
una vez a la semana la quitan por la
noche hacia las 8 hasta el día siguiente
lydia aprovecha para hacer las tareas
domésticas y para refrescarse
el agua es vida si no tenemos agua no
podemos hacer nada realmente no podemos
hacer nada
guadalupe vive al ritmo de los cortes de
agua sin embargo en la isla abundan los
ríos y las cascadas el problema es que
el sistema de tuberías fue construido en
los años 50 y nunca se le ha hecho
mantenimiento por todas partes hay fugas
como esta el 63 por ciento del agua se
pierde pero las tuberías no son el único
problema
en cap este velo se producirá a más del
60% de los bananos hace unos 30 años así
que las tierras de camps esther están
llenas de flor de jona
la flor de con un pesticida utilizado
durante mucho tiempo en los cultivos
bananeros afectó la calidad del agua
pero este concejal de la oposición
denunció a otro escándalo esta estación
depuradora de aguas residuales costó 13
millones de euros europa financió un 53
por ciento de su construcción pero nunca
ha funcionado
es un sistema que ha estado abandonado
desde su inauguración en 2003
la causa según él es la mala gestión de
las autoridades locales
acabamos de votar el presupuesto inicial
que tiene un déficit de 85 millones de
euros 75 millones de deuda 56 millones
para los proveedores sin contar los
bancos las autoridades de la comunidad
local no tienen los medios financieros
para hacer funcionar esta estación
la consecuencia es que las aguas
residuales terminan en el mar en la isla
dos tercios de las estaciones
depuradoras no siguen la normativa una
inminente amenaza ambiental
[Música]
estamos en fort del gres aquí tuvo lugar
la rebelión contra las tropas francesas
que llegaron para restablecer la
esclavitud en 1802 es un símbolo de las
tensiones que aún persisten entre parís
y su antigua colonia nos acompaña a
rafael lapan abogado escritor y
presidente de la asociación guadalupana
misma
rafael la pan vemos en guadalupe una
desconfianza es el gobierno central cómo
hacer para superar esta brecha
[Música]
es una fractura que viene de lejos la
zona fractura que viene de la historia
de guadalupe con francia hecho que se
instale la desconfianza y se hacía el
solo porque las ideas siempre han sido
reprimidas a veces hasta con sangre esta
fractura es también como heredar una
dualidad el somos un departamento
francés de ultramar esto quiere decir
supuestamente
que los guadalupeños son iguales a
cualquier francés o francesa pero al
mismo tiempo vivimos al otro lado del
océano en el caribe incluso quisiéramos
tener una igualdad total con nosotros
ciudadanos franceses
total en la práctica aquí no tenemos
acceso fácil al agua potable y conseguir
una vivienda es particularmente
complicado la realidad es que somos hoy
uno de los departamentos franceses más
viejos
con éxodo de nuestra juventud que parte
con su profundidad con su tecnicismo que
no vuelve a instalarse que refleja
también una falta de atractivo del
territorio
la exigencia del pase sanitario aquí
generó grandes protestas como afectó es
la relación entre parís y guadalupe
el 12 de julio de 2021 el presidente de
la república habló desde la torre eiffel
todos nos acordamos con un discurso
marcial donde explicaba que se iba a
comer un pasaporte sanitario en ese
momento un 70% de los franceses estaba
bastante más se dirigía a un país
mayoritariamente inoculado pero la
realidad de guadalupe era totalmente
diferente a las personas no vacunadas
llegaban a un ctv por ciento frente a un
30 por ciento de personas vacunadas
en cualquier lugar con esta tasa de
vacunación
éramos tenido esta desconfianza de la
población
se hubiera hablado del fracaso de la
política de vacunación
en guadalupe en cambio hablamos de los
rebeldes guadalupeños que se niegan a
aceptar una política de vacunación que
desde mi punto de vista no era la
adecuada en realidad esto es lo que
ocurre en la política de vacunación
pero podría ocurrir con cualquier otro
tema la llama vino con respecto a la
crisis sanitaria
pero hubiera podido venir del agua de la
gestión de residuos o cualquier política
pública que tenga problemas en guadalupe
y que causa el sufrimiento de los
guadalupeños
su trabajo consiste en animar a los
guadalupeños a tomar el futuro en sus
manos de qué se trata concretamente
y
obviamente está nuestra asociación jaime
món que es un think tank y nos
propusimos hacer cuatro preguntas a los
guadalupeños como ves guadalupe hoy como
debería ser nuestra isla como será
guadalupe dentro de 20 años y luego les
preguntamos en criollo cómo trabajas
para hacer realidad la guadalupe que
sueñas
es un poco una transformación de lo que
dijo john f.kennedy
no te preguntes qué puede hacer tu país
por ti y qué puedes hacer tú por tu país
se trata de animar a todos a participar
en la transformación del país y
finalmente cuál debiera ser la prioridad
del futuro gobierno con respecto a la
relación entre francia y sus territorios
de ultramar
las expectativas son particularmente
importantes y concretas y nos gustaría
transformarlas en acciones rápidamente
hablamos antes del agua también
hablábamos de herencia común mencionamos
la cuestión de la fuga de cerebros pero
más allá de eso todas estas cuestiones
están íntimamente ligadas a la relación
que tiene guadalupe con el hexágono para
mí es necesario cambiar el paradigma
tenemos que ser capaces de salir de una
relación paternalista para entrar en una
relación de socios iguales y cómo se
hace esto a través por ejemplo del
desarrollo económico hace unos 20 años
empezamos a plantearnos la cuestión de
que desarrollo queremos para los
territorios ultramar y oscilamos entre
el desarrollo indígena y sistema de
convergencia es decir tener exactamente
el mismo nivel de desarrollo de
guadalupe que en la francia continental
sin haber considerado los modelos
disponibles y el real potencial del
territorio estuve a favor de dejar que
los territorios determinen qué tipo de
desarrollo económico les gustaría tener
que el que estrategia económica
prefieren aplicar
muchas gracias rafael evans por esta
entrevista con 34 meses
y desde esta playa paradisíaca decimos
adiós a este capítulo de nuestro tour
por francia los dejamos disfrutando
porque nosotros vamos hacia parís
[Música]